PETE:  GO AHEAD, SORRY.
JEDEDIAH:  POWERFUL MESSAGES
FROM PEOPLE IN SACRAMENTO,
CALIFORNIA.
WE’RE SEEING PROTESTS POP UP
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA MAKING SOME PRETTY
STRONG STATEMENTS THERE.
WE’RE GOING TO BRING IN
CALIFORNIA GOP CONGRESSMAN DEVIN
NEWNUNES NOW.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
MATTERING THE COMMENTS FROM
PROTESTERS IN CALIFORNIA?
>> I THINK IT’S GOING TO GET A
LOT WORSE.
THE GOVERNOR IS PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS ON A DAILY BASIS.
WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR SEVERAL WEEKS NOW WITH WHERE
BEACHES ARE OPEN, OTHER BEACHES
ARE NOT.
WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY, I WENT
TO COSTCO WHICH I LIKE TO DO.
THE LINES WERE LONGER THAN I’VE
SEEN LINES AT DISNEYLAND.
I STOOD IN THE LINE FOR 30
MINUTES TO GET MY FOOD.
THERE WERE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF MY FELLOW CALIFORNIANS THERE.
AND I’M ALL FOR COSTCO BEING
OPEN.
WHEN I FINALLY GOT TO THE
CHECKOUT COUNTER, I HAD PICKED
UP LAMB AND CHICKEN.
I WAS TOLD I COULD ONLY BUY
THREE PACKAGES.
SO I SENT THE CHICKEN BACK, TOOK
WITH THE LAMB.
NOT THAT THE VIEWERS WANT TO
KNOW WHAT I HAD FOR DINNER LAST
NIGHT.
BUT I JUST THINK THIS IS
LUDICROUS.
THE GOVERNOR NOW IS TREATING
DIFFERENT COUNTIES, COUNTIES
THAT HAVE VOTED TO SAY, HEY,
WE’RE GOING TO OPEN UP, THEY’RE
BEING PUNISHED.
I TALKED TO A COUPLE OF OUR
LOCAL CITY COUNCIL AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS YESTERDAY AND THEY
TOLD ME THAT THEY’RE BEING
INTIMIDATED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
HIS STAFF.
NOW, TO ME, THAT’S EXTORTION.
YOU CAN’T USE FEDERAL AND STATE
TAX DOLLARS WHERE YOU DISAGREE
WITH SOMEONE’S POLICIES OR
POLITICS AND PUNISH THEM.
AND REMEMBER, THIS IS WHEN
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES ARE WIDE
OPEN, THE RESTAURANTS ARE OPEN.
SO THIS IS BECOMING -- IT’S
GETTING WORSE AND WORSE AND
WORSE AND I THINK IT’S VERY,
VERY FRUSTRATING FOR A LOT OF
FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA.
GRIFF:  TALK ABOUT FRUSTRATING.
WE WANT TO BRING IN RYAN
DRISCOLL, A PERFORMER ON THE
CRUISE SHIP SEA BORNE ODYSSEY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
I UNDERSTAND YOU WERE STUCK ON
THAT SHIP FOR SOME 80 DAYS
DURING THE PANDEMIC, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
IT WAS A CRAZY TIME.
GRIFF:  CONGRESSMAN NUNES HELPED
BRING YOU HOME.
EXPLAIN.
>> YES, I’M VERY THANKFUL TO
CONGRESSMAN NUNES AND HIS
OFFICE.
THEY ALL HELPED ME GET HOME
QUICKER AND SAFER.
THEY WERE PUTTING PRESSURE ON
THE LOCAL BRIDGETOWN AND
BARBADOS GOVERNMENT, WORKING
WITH THE U.S. STATE DEPARTMENT
AND U.S. EMBASSY IN BRIDGETOWN
TO ARRANGE A CHARTER FLIGHT TO
BRING BACK AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
I WAS ONE OF THOSE LUCKY
AMERICANS THAT GOT TO COME HOME
ON THAT FLIGHT.
GRIFF:
PETE:.PETE:  WHAT WOULD IT HAVE
LIKE IF YOU DIDN’T HAVE A
CONGRESSMAN ABLE TO WEIGH IN FOR
YOU.
COULD YOU OTHERWISE STILL BE
STUCK?
>> I THINK WITHOUT CONGRESSMAN
NUNES AND HIS AMAZING STAFF IN
CALIFORNIA, I WOULD NOT BE HERE
RIGHT NOW IN SUNNY SAN DIEGO.
I WOULD BE STUCK ON THAT SHIP
LIKE MANY OF MY FRIENDS ARE
STILL STUCK ON SHIPS AROUND THE
WORLD.
SO I’M VERY THANKFUL TO BE BACK.
JEDEDIAH:  CONGRESSMAN, WHAT HAS
IT MEANT FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
HELP BRING RYAN HOME.
>> IT’S ONE OF THE REALLY ONLY
GOOD PARTS LEFT ABOUT THIS JOB,
IS A LOT OF TIMES WE’RE THE LAST
LINE WHEN PEOPLE GET TO US,
WE’RE THEIR LAST HOPE.
AND WE’VE HAD A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
RYAN’S CASE, ALL THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
HAVE HAD SIMILAR SITUATIONS, BUT
RYAN’S WAS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT TOOK SO
LONG.
AND I’M ACTUALLY THANKFUL THAT
HE DID GET BACK AND I WISH HE
WOULD HAVE GOT BACK A LOT SOONER
TO BE WITH HIS FAMILY BACK HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE STILL HAVE SOME PEOPLE
STILL OVERSEAS, TRAPPED OVERSEAS
WHO CAN’T GET HOME.
WE’RE STILL WORKING ON THOSE
CASES.
PETE:  I KNOW THIS IS NOT
RELATED TO THE CRUISE SHIP BUT
ANY UPDATES ON THE
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON IN
WASHINGTON AS FAR AS WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
>> WELL, IF YOU’RE LOOKING AT
WHAT JUDGE SULLIVAN IS DOING, I
THINK THIS IS REALLY OUT OF LEFT
FIELD.
I HEARD YOU TALKING TO DOUG
COLLINS FROM GEORGIA EARLIER IN
THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS A VERY ODD CASE.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS SIT THERE
AND LOOK AND SAY WAIT A SECOND,
ISN’T THIS A FEDERAL JUDGE, BEEN
ON THE BENCH FOR A REALLY LONG
TIME.
WHY WOULD HE POSSIBLY NEED A
LAWYER?
HE HAS TO UNDERSTAND THE LAW.
HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO
HIS FELLOW JUDGES THAT ARE
EVALUATING THIS CASE.
IT’S REALLY UNPRECEDENTED TO SEE
SOMEONE TAKE IT UPON THEMSELF TO
BE THE JUDGE, JURY AND
PROSECUTION.
BEING THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS DROPPED THE
CHARGES.
SO WE’RE CONTINUING TO MONITOR.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE’RE WORKING
ON IS LOOKING AT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AND EVERYTHING
SURROUNDING THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE WE ARE
LOOKING TO MAKE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS BASED ON WHAT OCCURRED
DURING THAT MUELLER PROSECUTION.
PETE:  RYAN, WE’RE GLAD YOU’RE
BACK.
ENJOY SUNNY SAN DIEGO.
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN GO TO THE
BEACH EVENTUALLY.
CONGRESSMAN, WE LOVE WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SAY.
I WOULD HAVE SKIPPED THE LAMB
AND GONE WITH THE CHICKEN.
I DISAGREE WITH THAT.